[APPLAUSE]
ROMAIN MARDOT: Hi guys.
My name is Romain
and I'm working
as a partner development manager
for the Google Play team.
I am taking care
of partners that
are based in central
Europe and Russia,
and I'm based in Moscow.
Today I will be talking
about the importance
of live operations in the
lifecycle of a mobile product.
Also later on, I will
be joined by Stefan,
who will be talking about one
of the examples that were kindly
shared with us by his company.
So let's start.
First of all, a quick
round about what's
today's last presentation
is going to be about.
Well first of all, I'll try
to define live operations
and explain why
they are important.
Then I will go through four
examples that were kindly
shared with us by our partners.
There are some people
present in the room.
Thank you very much guys.
And I will wrap up by giving
some recommendations and best
practices.
Actually, live operations
is a pretty large field
of operations.
And it's like
marketing, it touches
of lot of domains inside of
the video game publisher.
And there were a
lot of cool examples
and best practices
that were already
shared before so I hope
that you will enjoy
the middle part of the
presentation that actually
brings more examples and data to
illustrate what we are saying.
So this is, sorry,
skip the menu part.
Now, what are liveops?
Probably many of you have
heard this definition already,
[? right, in ?] video
gaming, especially nowadays.
We are talking about
running a game as a service.
We are not at the point where
we were developing a product
and then launching
it on the market
and leaving it sitting there.
Now most of the most
successful products
that are available
in the mobile sphere
or as a video
gaming platforms are
being operated by companies.
So in this very
context I'm going
to talk about strategy
distribution, or interactions
that you might have
with the players that
aim to increase
their engagement,
in some cases monetization.
Overall, it's to bring more fun.
Sometimes they will help
you to reduce your churn
because English players are
staying longer, obviously,
or even bring some of them back.
So what are the main
components of live operations?
When we are talking
about operations
we're talking about
customer relations.
Customer relations includes news
posting, interaction on forums,
interaction on social networks.
Previously we had
some great examples.
It also includes sales
and promotions, bundles,
rare items, activation
or distribution, contests
and tournaments.
Business intelligence.
Business intelligence, in
terms of live operation
is a very important factor.
When talking about
mobile gaming publishing
we all know this
[INAUDIBLE] KPIs
like monthly, daily active
users, retention, conversion
to players.
But business intelligence, when
it comes to live operations,
is your capacity of measuring
the impact of the actions
that you are creating,
these operations
that you are creating
for your player's base.
And here you have to be
always in front of the curve.
If your product is
growing you need
to be proactive and create
activities that will actually
even increase this trend.
If you think that
you are, obviously,
[INAUDIBLE] in revenue or
[INAUDIBLE] your active users
is going down, here
again, you actually
have to be twice more
productive in terms of creating
different activities.
Types of LiveOps.
So there are liveops
that can be bound
to the coded updates, generally
called patches in the industry.
And they come to hide the
importance of their new modes
or story that you
introduce to the game.
They can also emphasize
the importance
of new characters, story, or
skills, or new game mechanics
that you have.
Targeted?
They are more bound
to player groups.
They depend on
seasons, on regions.
They also depend on
the progress sometimes
the players have
made in the game.
We actually had a very good
example half an hour ago.
[INAUDIBLE] to the
moments when you think
that the players will churn.
This is just a small reminder.
When you are tailoring your live
operations for local markets
you need to make sure that you
think globally because even
the most famous events that
we are all used to celebrate
might occur at different
times of the year
in different countries.
If we take the example
of Easter, or like when
the Christmas is
celebrated in Russia,
and they might not be
celebrated in the same way.
So here you have
to be quite smart
and, again, think globally.
This [? slide ?] is
actually pretty famous,
especially for those that
are doing game development.
You know that you have to tailor
your live operations depending
on a player's objectives.
We all know that
competition between players
is one of the
strongest drivers when
it comes to increased
players engagement revenue
because it's competition.
But not everyone likes
direct confrontation.
Some people like
playing a product
but discovering it
under a different way.
Some people, as we
know, are achievers,
some people get there just
for the social component
because they want to stay
connected with other users.
Some people like tourism,
they're exploring content.
So when creating
a new opportunity
you have to think about
these types of players.
As mentioned several times
today, it's all about business,
right?
So when you are
creating live operations
you also have to take your
own goals into consideration.
Here again, we are talking
retention and engagement.
We need to make
sure that the events
that you create,
they do not burn,
for instance, your
players' base because you
are, for instance,
delivering too much
content at the same time.
That you monetize
these players properly.
Later on we will actually
have a really cool example
of such a case.
That you drive your players
to content properly because
technically and normally, when
your product is being released
you are the ones who know
your product in the best way.
So you teach people,
you educate them
on how to go
through it properly.
And marketing.
Marketing here is,
obviously, when
you are collecting or gathering
resources inside your company
to raise the hype
around an event that
is happening in your product.
It's also a good opportunity
to acquire new users.
So this scenario should be used.
It's also a nice moment to
cross-promote your product.
Obviously, you have more
than one in your portfolio.
And the final step, when
tailoring your live operations
you have to tailor them for the
entire base of your players.
And by entire we
mean the players
that are still to join your
project, those that left,
and different players that
are at a different level
of the progress of your game.
Obviously you have not to
forget about the core players
because those are
usually the ones that
influence the community
in the best way
and promote your product often.
So why it is important to
run live operations nowadays?
Because the content
is king and we
know that players are consuming
it at a different level.
So you need to make sure that,
through your interactions
or the game mechanics, you
are present for the players
whenever they want to
interact with your product.
It's very important and its one
of the best ways to keep them
engaged because time is money.
We all know that, right?
And sometimes, when
your development team
and the artists are working
on creating new code
and new patch you can
come up with an event that
will have the same impact,
or sometimes even better,
to keep your users
engaged, to show
them the best out of the game.
One example might be like going
through levels of your game,
or creating different
tournaments based
on achievements or
photo-sharing contests.
Those are pretty, let's say,
cheap and efficient solutions
to bring something additional
and new about the game.
Again, because
engagement is essential,
here featuring [INAUDIBLE].
And people get used
to talking to you.
And the more efficient
you are the more likely
you are to reach
your users when you
try to share some important
information about the upcoming
event and the upcoming patch.
People will just
stay engaged longer.
Because we all know that
acquisition costs are high
and the products that are
currently on the market,
the top grossing
ones, are mature,
so its one of the best ways to
optimize your lifetime value.
It makes your traffic
acquisition more efficient.
Players stay longer,
probably paying more.
So it's helping to
save some money.
And because we all do
products for people
we are creating apps.
And even if you are interfacing
with a game through a device
you still like feeling
a human presence behind.
This is why liveops
is important.
In fact, it's not about
short-term spikes in revenue,
or daily active users.
It's really about building
long-term, lifetime relations
and value with your players.
So now I will be going through
some examples that were
shared with us by our partners.
Here we are featuring Wargaming,
studio from Belarus, Zeptolab,
UK, Madfinger Games, from Czech
Republic, and Creative Mobile.
So Stefan Ruhle,
from Creative Mobile
will be talking about the
initiative on his own.
So first example, Wargaming.
Pretty interesting case.
It was a live operation that was
created for the entire player's
base without creating any code.
So what the guys
did is that they
use their web-based website
to pull the statistical data
from the service and organize a
competition among all players,
where every region
was represented
by different characters.
So here you can see a cowboy
representing the North America,
and a Russian night
with a Russian tank.
And players were
obviously fighting
for different objectives.
The news about this
contest was just
pushed through Wargaming
normal networks.
And actually what happened is
that just once the news were
released, the number
of daily active users
has instantly increased by 4%.
This is without any additional
user acquisition, which was
actually quite a smart move.
But besides that, by
introducing some smart goals
for the community what
Wargaming managed to reach
is to increase its
battle intensity by 22%,
to increase its in-game
purchases by almost twice,
and to increase their
hard currency, which
is gold in this game, by 117%.
And this is just by
creating an event
and advertising it through the
web page and the community.
There is another thing
that pops up to the game,
and is quite interesting
for analysis.
It's a tank.
As I was saying at the
beginning, if you remember,
I mentioned rare
items activation.
So this tank was initially
coded and added to the game
but pops up only
on rare occasions.
Once [? you ?] request
people can get it for free.
Or, just before
Christmas in December,
it appears in a special bundle.
So whenever this
tank appears it just
does massive results
in terms of sales
because people know how
this tank is legendary.
And sometimes they are
waiting for it purposely.
So as you can see
here, the number
of tanks that are sold
within the first three days
is increasing by 40%.
It is the best selling
tank of all times.
It drives 30% of
revenue for months
and it creates a lot
of new paying users.
5.7% of people who bought
the bundle with this tank
paid within the ecosystem
for the first time.
So it's quite a smart move.
This is a chart
showing the number
of sales of this
legendary tank, Type 59,
comparing to other tanks.
And the E 25 is one of the
most popular and available
in the game the whole time.
This is actually quite cool.
So next example
is from Zeptolab.
Thank you Lana for
giving us the info.
Those cases are actually pretty
interesting because not only
do they show the results of
some actions that were performed
by the partner but
they were actually
done in the context
of A/B testing.
So now you will be seeing how
different changes of variables
bring different results.
So in this case is
when additional content
was added to a premium chess.
Group A the control
group, so the content
that was usually
available in the game.
Then you have Groups B, C,
and D. And what you can see
is that it's not the
group that received
the most of the premium
content that added the most
value to the player's lifetime.
So this is actually
one of the cases
where you have to balance
the content that you
deliver properly.
Another example is
personalized offers.
Before, the [INAUDIBLE]
had an offer that
was universal for all players.
But then they decided
to include the content
based on the progress that
the players have already
made to the game.
And here again, we can
see that the [INAUDIBLE]
has increased by 45%.
Another example.
This is the cross-promotion
factor, which I mentioned.
This is the installs that are
being driven by Cut the Rope,
we all probably know this
game, to King of Chiefs.
So here again,
amazing results were
reached in terms of
conversion to installs.
And on the right part,
or actually, it's
still the right
part for you, you
can see different
examples of icons
that were used for reaching
those objectives and the impact
it has.
The very last one,
which I personally like.
So if you can see, it actually
features a special Android
[? king, ?] that was actually
added to the game and featured
on the store through a
[? banner. ?] So here again,
a good moment, good
initiative, and good idea.
The costume has become
four times more popular
than other costumes in the game.
So you have 1% of
players reported using it
at least once and 10% of players
are wearing it on daily basis.
[ROMAIN LAUGHING]
Pretty cooL, right?
Last example on my
side before Stefan
comes to the stage, Madfinger.
Thank you for providing the
example guys, Mark, [INAUDIBLE]
but thank you.
On the left part of the slide,
it's not a live operation but
as I managed a very
cool example on how
the introduction of a PDP
mode changes games KPIs.
So the game was
released one year ago.
It has already 15 million
of installs worldwide.
But when these guys introduced
the PDP mode back in May,
it actually increased
the number of players
that converted to them by 100%.
And their [? pool ?]
also went up.
And then, we came up with a
team with the first purchase
offer that was adding additional
content to the players who
were playing PDP.
And here, as you
can see, the results
were also amazing in
terms of conversion
to paying users and
the increase of ARPU.
And the project is
actually doing very well.
And it's a very cool game.
So now, it's Stefan's turn
to talk about the initiative.
Please welcome Stefan.
[APPLAUSE]
STEFAN RUHLE: Hello.
You hear me?
OK.
Yeah.
Thank you Romain and thank you
Google for actually hosting
a very, very pleasant event.
I actually had the opportunity
to visit the Playtime event
in Berlin but I must say London
is like four times bigger here,
definitely.
It is even an honor to
be mentioned among all
those great, great developers.
I love King of Thieves, I
even have that on my phone.
So if you're looking for a
good game for lots of fun,
definitely download that.
Let's start with a question.
Who knows Fetty Wap?
That's like two.
That's actually, usually
the answer I get in Europe.
Well, let's quickly
look who is Fetty Wap.
Fetty Wap is an
American hip hop artist
who rose to actually lots
of publicity in 2015.
He has one billion
YouTube channel
with like 1 billion views.
He has songs like
"Trap Queen," "679."
He works with
David [? Guetta, ?]
with SIA, with Blake, so
definitely, lots of big guys.
And he is among the top 10 most
listened artists on Pandora,
Spotify, and Apple music.
He's even been
nominated many times
for two Grammy
nominations already,
multiple VMA and
Billboard Awards.
And what actually rose
some interest for us,
he shares a big passion for
cars, ATVs, and motorcycles,
actually anything
that has wheels.
And so, he got in touch
with us with his management
and we started talking about
actually doing something
together based on
one of our games.
We quickly realized
that he's actually
interested in doing
more than just
being the icon of the
game, actually doing
more and providing lots
of, lots of support.
And that actually resulted in
one very nice game trailer,
which I wanted to show now.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[CAR REVVING ENGINE]
[FETTY WAP SINGING]
- Score.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
STEFAN RUHLE: OK.
That worked.
Yeah, that was
Nitro Nation Story,
so it's like a sister
game of Nitro Nation
and Heavenly Story
drive racing game.
And we work with the concept
of real rewards there.
So we rewrote the
storyline to focus
on Fetty Wap and
his crew, that's
Monty and lots of other people.
We added new soundtracks.
There's music added
to the game, which
will be first
released to the game
and then later to this
audience, actually.
We have lots of merchandise
from [? them, ?] from T-shirts,
to caps, to hoodies, to
later even, a meet and greet,
which will be result
in a tournament.
And that actually resulted in
very, very impressive numbers.
Now we had a launch event
in New York together
was with Fetty Wap, and
lots of his influences,
lots of his friends.
That actually resulted that
we were among top two searched
game, actually
trending searches,
for the Fetty Wap game.
Our retention went high.
We got 50% retention
in the first months.
Skyrocket with a
rating on Google Play,
as well for the review score.
And we doubled our revenue.
So that's definitely,
I would say, a liveop
which worked out for us.
And here is just a little bit to
see the update before Fetty Wap
and after Fetty Wap.
But now many of you will agree
that the pool of celebrities
is limited and you don't
want to use, I don't know,
George Clooney for the next
skydiving app, or something
like this.
So it needs to stay authentic.
And there's another way of
working, not with celebrities
but working with
brands, what we did,
and that is with
our-- that's why
I said sister game, that's
like the flagship title Nitro
Nation.
That's like one big family.
And there we started to
introduce more and more brands
for live operations.
And we started to work with
Tec Speed Wheels, that's
a German rim manufacturer,
BBS [? Barbette, ?] many, many
we reached out.
And rim manufacturers,
they actually
do tournaments, which are
already written in the game.
But on quarterly
results we can actually
draw out a set of real rims.
So if anyone is actually in
need of real rims for his car,
definitely play a little
bit of Nitro Nation.
And something else, what we did
there, what I'm really, really
proud about is we won Hankook.
I don't know who knows Hankook
but it's a tire sponsor, not
tire sponsor, it's a
it's a tire manufacturer.
But we won them as an official
tire sponsor four Nitro Nation.
I think are currently
number seven or number six
in the world, just quickly
behind guys like Continental,
Dunlop, Michelin.
So definitely big names.
And what we did with them
is event collaboration.
So these guys are regularly
going to car exhibitions.
And quickly before
we go into that,
I think most of the
mobile game developers
can agree with me that
exhibitions for mobile game
developers, for
example, the gamescom,
to be present in the
entertainment area
is not really the best
deal because you need
to compete with Battlefield
1, Watch Dogs 2,
like people running
into the halls
to see that not to see
the next mobile game.
And that's why we realize
it's actually a good time
to do liveops together with some
big brands on car exhibitions.
So we went to Essen
Motor Show last year
together with Hankook.
And these are typical
South Korean Hancook girls,
which are always using.
And so we work
together with them.
We invited some YouTubers.
We had a big show there.
We were part of their
booth and we actually
created video content on YouTube
with the YouTubers and Hankook
together, which reached
over a million views
in a couple of days.
So many of you said,
the Essen Motor Show
contacted us afterwards
and told like next time
you come you please tell us,
So that definitely worked out.
And yeah, actually, I need to
rush through because Romain
wanted to go next.
ROMAIN MARDOT: Thank you Stefan.
STEFAN RUHLE: No problem.
[APPLAUSE]
ROMAIN MARDOT: So the day
was quite [INAUDIBLE].
I'm not going to repeat
everything again.
Its just a small stress
on the fact that Google
is actually amazing at
offering different services.
And a lot of good stuff
was mentioned today.
Just a reminder,
when we were talking
about getting additional
events into your game,
you know that you can create
them through our services,
right?
And we have really
strong analytics tools
that are included in the
Google Play Developer Console.
And as mentioned
earlier, its actually
in the very heart of Firebase.
So we just hope that those
tools will help you guys
developing better
products, understanding
your audience better,
and using them for free.
It's a nice solution.
Then the points that you
have to consider it's,
again, just a kind of wrap up.
What is important when
it comes to liveops?
It's obviously knowing
what kind of tools
that you have to run
liveops inside your game.
If you are in the process
of developing a new product
you should certainly make
sure that you have one.
That you have the
possibility to create events
based on different players
needs on different seasons
or on different regions.
That you have the possibility
to grant [? or activate ?] items
inside your product
without patching it.
That you can know
what offers are
relevant to different
regions and you
know what are the best price
points for the people who
are likely to buy
something in your game.
And that you have
also team members
that understand the product and
can work with the community.
So if there are like four--
forget about one slide.
This is actually how to
increase your chances.
You know that from
time to time we
are contacting you
about some initiatives
that we are launching, like
Game Fest or summer deals.
Its actually one
of the best ways
to get into it
because we actually
check if you guys can adjust
your prices accordingly,
or according to the theme
of the deal, for instance.
Or if the content
that is in your game
is relevant to the kind of
[INAUDIBLE] network rating.
So it's just another idea on how
to promote your product better.
And as I said,
here's four points
that are very important
for this presentation.
Please invest into liveops
backend tools and team.
And it also applies to
the Players Stats API.
Invest in talented
people who do really
care and know how to work
and promote your project.
Invest into business analytics.
This is not a luxury solution,
this is very helpful.
And through the examples
you've just seen,
we know that it works.
And in your daily work
you also know that works.
And two important
factors, as I said,
it's also about
human interactions.
Show to your players that
they are important to you.
And don't forget about
those that haven't joined
the project or those who left.
They might be people, as shown
with other examples, that
might come back.
[MUSIC PLAYING]